[ __ ] hell as a Hollywood actor Idris
Elba has made a career out of playing a
tough guy now he's about to find out if
he really is one he set himself an
extraordinary personal challenge to
become a pro kickboxer in just 12 months
one two
ciarán kettle is a 3 x k1 kickboxing
world champion an owner of the famous
double K gym on the outskirts of London
since his retirement from the ring he's
trained no less than 16 world champions
today Idris is going to get a wake-up
call as Kirin shows him what level of
fitness you need to be a pro fighter
actor aside you know I will break my
nose for this fight
I put one of my world champions Jamie
wheeling against him who's fast slick
and a lot of shots in it's just his
first spar and Idris is already
complaining of an injury I'm not there
yeah my head I am
this is felt weak bear to see my quad
doctor right since a sparring session
Idris has been in excruciating pain
what we've got to do at the moment is
forget about fighting we need to get a
surgical opinion and then worry about
fighting after that
[Music]
besides just by out of surgery waiting
game now hopefully this works man cuz I
just want to get into trading gentlemen
July my robe
ciarán desperately needs to make up time
he decides they'll go straight on a
six-day training camp to Japan the home
of k1 fighting
but before that they're going to the
island of Okinawa to see a man who will
provide Idris with a vital tool the
ability to endure pain
his name is shin Joe sensei two three
okay I can't please no more [ __ ] out
Wow Wow
now left Oh
[Music]
you can see that the painter it just was
going further Mysore stood by and
watched I didn't enjoy that I felt super
exposed that I was super weak Kieran's
just told Idris he's going to have his
first proper heavyweight spa after this
bar I know if he's got it or if it's
time for me to walk away this is huge
gonna spa
wait a minute oh wow he just nori of us
nice me when interes saw his opponent
nori knows 90 kilos I think he realized
I'm gonna be infra scrap here
I didn't start well features because
right away nori applied lots of pressure
nor we have a shy way I'm just playing
around
got a little bit dirty as well
[Music]
Idris wanted to throw in the town this
is it gonna be tired yeah you can still
throw back but what I saw next even took
me by surprise that's got pain only
squares me on probably a bit of a
masochist in that way cut me on a copy
back I saw him I saw in his eyes he
didn't like installing we did gave me a
little bit more respect seen all his
face as well start to swell up again
some clean shots from good kicks as well
and for the first time I thought who got
someone genuine here
a genuine fighter
you